how's it going my demon sponge what's
that that's the wrong channel and it's
the right channel just keep going and
pretend nothing happened all right
well today we got to play with the
oculus there's a few new awesome games
coming out and I thought we're gonna
check them out together let's do it it's
demon Bros wait now I'm confused in this
first game where you play as a platypus
I bet you're jealous now haters oh god
the game just starts hello hello I'm a
platypus
everyone will baby in my [ __ ] Ness hey
sugar platypus platypus platypus
everybody be a [ __ ] platypus
what the hell is going on just make
everything turn into balloons
that's the lap of a platypus I like my
mouth it's it's turning me on a little
bit to be honest first wrong
yes got ya look at the mountains
so Sugoi this is the best game I ever
played I never said that before so you
know it's true oh god what are you doing
here tree trees trying to make out with
me how are you doing over there
I gave any game that I can yell in it's
just like oh they're high oh man oh god
this game is give me a weird trip man oh
man uh-oh what's good it's that a bunch
of slender man's
what is tight the jam has changed but I
like it
it's still Sugoi it's still kawaii can't
you [ __ ] see I pee on your tree
[ __ ] Sugoi Sugoi on Oh dick sis don't
be so [ __ ] happy I just murdered that
guy why is this it is that cry cry cries
I yo academic
No oh god buddy Sugoi by the power of
kawaii
I command you just step aside what's
that was that cheesy I think that was
pretty badass if I can see Bruce Lee or
someone do that [ __ ] step aside to the
rainbow the guy on you
eisah go your ass I stick all your ass
to balloons yes we go there's actually
stuff over there holy [ __ ]
ah-ha whoa geez says too scared of the
living to go out of me what that [ __ ] is
happening over there I'm not even gonna
ask I'm not even gonna ask what the [ __ ]
oculus that makes sense
ah that makes perfect sense men nobody
thought being a platypus is this amazing
I can Sugoi the cat oh my god I can
break the rainbow this is to escape I'm
crying the real tears now I'm crying for
the first years this is too beautiful
part of the baby soon hi I missed what
was that what did you do did the baby
[ __ ] on the Oreos oh it's those candies
I loved us oh god I'm starting to feel
really sick sick of not playing this
game because it's amazing did that make
sense I think yes [ __ ] step aside I am
NOT why they oh mighty overlord of Sugoi
actually I am kill it's junk we did it I
kissed 37 animals that's pretty good
and we went to space well I mean I don't
want to like an exaggerated or anything
like that but this has to be probably
the best game and
out of any game that has ever been made
and no one should even try anymore this
is this done there won't be any more
games after this what just happened it's
this real life and yeah why are you so
ugly all the sudden put me back in put
me back in please that was ridiculous I
love it
my game really changed me back I'm just
sitting here staring at the screen and I
don't know how to react to anything
anymore all right
oh we have won our game another game
alright next game is supposed to be the
best 90s simulator experience of all
time it's supposed to be for the dk2 I
can't get that [ __ ] I bought the DK 2
which is like the upgraded one just
[ __ ] work I hate yeah this works at
least I don't give a [ __ ] so I'm gonna
play with it and we're gonna have fun it
looks like [ __ ] for me but I don't care
at least it works play please here we go
how today oh my god yes yes this is the
greatest game of all time no wait the
Platypus game it there we go
yes this is what I'm talking about when
I talk about hardcore gaming yes yes yes
[Music]
I'm feeling it
[ __ ] it's my it's my special move oh my
neck ah ah now I can't escape it's too
hardcore for me I'll cut cut
alright I'm gonna have to break it there
hope you guys enjoy this video if you
did hit that like button as always thank
you for doing it it's a scratch I come
abroad today don't you bro yet come on
stay awesome brothers love you
[Music]